you know it's so cool to have the
legends guys joining us on the CW truly
superheroes everywhere so what should we
call a grouping of superheroes all in
one place what about a super swarm that
works and who better to wrangle this
super swarm than DC entertainments Geoff
Johns I feel like I was just out here
actually I but I really like standing
here so I can ask them questions I'm
super excited with legends of tomorrow
because it is the very first DC
entertainment team superhero show and
Greg Berlanti and Andrew Kreisberg and
Marc Guggenheim what they started with
arrow was so amazing and then we built
flash off that and now DC legends of
tomorrow celebrates expanding the DC
Universe and that's what we want to do
so I'm very very pleased and proud to
present executive producer Marc
Guggenheim Greg Berlanti our Hawkgirl
Ciara Renee Martin Stein himself Victor
Garber the atom bread and Ralph my
favorite villain of all time Captain
Cold Wentworth Miller
our canary Caity Lotz heatwave Dominic
Purcell is that the producer Phil
clemmer executive producer Sarah
Schecter and my good pal and DC geek
Andrew Kreisberg so I'm gonna start with
Greg and mark and Andrew and Phil and I
know the answer this on these questions
but I'm gonna ask them anyway
how so obviously we've introduced these
great characters except for a Hawkgirl
these great characters in the series
arrow and flash and the idea kind of
came to to do something with them
because there's so many wonderful heroes
and villains out there how are we gonna
see this show roll out from arrow and
flash this year well you know the the
first few episodes of arrow and flash
are gonna do what we call table setting
which is you know we've got various
characters that have to be put on the
chessboard so they can go into legends
for example of people in Starling city
feel that Ray Palmer died in a horrific
explosion and he needs to be restored
normal size sara is not dead or needs to
be knocked down where to be on
so using the the early episodes of both
shows to place these characters sort of
back on the table and then the crossover
will play into legends that will come on
in midseason so it's all very organic
and I knew one of the characters that we
haven't announced yet that will be part
of the show is a Hawkman so they'll be
coming in they like Hawkman good I like
fantastic
I'm gonna start with Brandon so just
because you're so cute when you fly out
at the end - that's not exactly I like
um so you scram you seem to enjoy being
a superhero but when when when you start
to become a part of a team how do you
think that's gonna change Ray Palmer's
approach is he gonna want to be the
alpha dog here I mean now if I call it
alpha male but he's definitely gonna
want to take charge a little bit and
give his input anyway being you know the
CEO of a multi-billion dollar company I
think he probably thinks he knows a
little bit about teamwork and all the
best
you know exercises to build a team so he
may be very enthusiastic whether he's
successful I don't know but I think he's
gonna be pretty gung-ho about the whole
experience
oh I think we're all glad you're not
dead we're all so glad kitty is how's
how's being dead and coming back gonna
change the canaries perspective and and
why the white canary well
we've seen with Theo and arrow that the
person who goes into the pit isn't
necessarily the same person who comes
out and there's you know consequences of
that so we'll see what happens when she
comes back to life but she was already
pretty crazy so I feel like now after
after that I at least I want her to go
just nuts off the walker that's my plan
and speaking of nuts Wentworth and
Dominic yeah
I take offense you're naughty aversion
your characters are also a little crazy
how do these like for you how do you
think these villains are these rogues
are gonna respond to being asked to join
part of a team well heatwave will be
pissed about it but has to has to do it
captain Cole is in charge as is always
the case
with the dynamic of Wentworth and myself
I'm always following and Wentworth how
is cold gonna respond to characters like
Ray Palmer Martin Stein
I think badly the answer is he's gonna
respond badly Leonard snart is used to
being the guy in charge and he's not a
team player and there's not an
altruistic bone in his body so the idea
of it's this big happy family pursuing a
glorious end I'm not sure he's totally
down for that but that's where the fun
is and I think that's what's gonna be
exciting for an audience to see is that
these guys have to work together but
it's gonna be a bumpy ride
speaking of bumpy ride so I know there's
a lot of time travel involved in Andrew
I know you're a Doctor Who fanatic geek
crazy man I've seen a few episodes
Vandal Savage we've already said he's a
big part of the show so can you tell us
a little bit about what these legends of
tomorrow gonna go up against yeah I mean
vandal is immortal you know he's been
around for thousands of years like we
said and you know when you know part of
the fun of the show is how do you defeat
somebody that you can't kill and since
time travel is gonna be such a huge part
of the show you know they're gonna be
meeting Vandal Savage in several
different time zones and you know part
of the fun of the show is watching you
know if they do something in one
timezone are they affecting it you know
the rest of history and I don't know
it's it's sort of a you know we keep
talking about how like on on arrow and
flash will come up with an idea and then
we'll
oh that's two crazy legends of tomorrow
all it is is the crazy ideas it's
numbers and and that's really exciting
because you know it was important for us
to not do the same show but we weren't
we're already doing our own we're
already doing flash and we really wanted
to do something different and and this
show is going to feel at you know as you
know radically different from flash as
flashes from arrow I'm sorry I have to
acknowledge this there are so many
people here thank you thank you so much
for coming out and lending your support
we love you guys Thanks
sorry box after you so uh Victor yes I
am overwhelmed you are unbelievable you
are so kind and generous and sweet all
of you not all of you but most of you I
know when when you accepted the role in
the show originally everybody was blown
away like we were so overjoyed to have
an actor to caliber join him and and you
brought so much to Martin Stein now that
Martin Stein is coming in to work with
all of these other heroes and some of
them villains and some of them novices
and rookies how do you think he's gonna
fit in with this group and why do you
think he's gonna get involved in a team
like this I think he's a combination of
many things but I think one thing is he
has a certain arrogance that believes
that he is actually capable of mediating
this dysfunctional family and that's
part of the fun of the character and
part of the fun of doing this role is
that he you know he does have high
ideals and is naive enough to think that
this could work and I think we'll see
how he does I'm confident that he will
make it confidently and we'll firestorm
be part of that equation a firestorm
will definitely be a part of it and
probably more than I
even realize probably Sierra
welcome to the DC Universe it's awesome
to have you join join the family and
what did you do to prepare for the role
of Hawkgirl well you guys were nice
enough to send me like a million comics
so I've been doing those um I also
watched the arrow and the flash finished
them because I caught up there but I've
also been I've been boxing and and doing
some martial arts just to kind of try
those things out cuz I really think
stunts are really cool and I'd like to
try them if I can
what's your favorite thing about Kendra
your favorite aspect about her character
I think just that there's I think the
reincarnation thing is like really
really awesome and I think it's gonna be
interesting to see her and these
different time periods or whatever and
and who she was then and who she is now
I mean it's gonna be as an actor this is
like an incredible challenge I get to
kind of play a lot of different people
and so Greg I have to go to you because
you're like the super producer you know
you're doing all these TV shows and I
know how hard you work on everything and
seeing the dedication and the passion
you put on everything it's amazing that
there you know that that that you do
what you do and when legends of tomorrow
was first happening it was like oh my
god can we do a superhero team show like
you at the helm I know we can but why
did you decide that it was the right
time to do you know from from flash to
arrow to now
that question gives me the perfect
opportunity actually to say thank you to
everybody in this room because really
it's the the show exists primarily for
two reasons one is the incredible
passion of the fans on arrow and flash
through the years it has been we've
obviously all watched that grow and then
the other the extraordinary actors who
have come on the show
whoo you know we just had a surplus of
so much talent and then finally just the
desire to do a real team up show in the
in the vein of Ocean's eleven and
Magnificent Seven and you know just a
great kind of superhero team-up but but
truthfully that this is this is entirely
really the result of just an incredible
incredible group of people who are
really support the shows and have helped
us grow them into something that we're
really proud of
and speaking of dedication I have SCAF I
have to ask you Brandon I know when you
first agreed to play the atom it was for
a smaller role no pun intended and now
you're you're committing to this show
which everyone's thrilled about why like
why do you find yourself drawn to the
superhero world why do you want to
continue to work in this this universe
this way well I don't know if I find
myself drawn or something else is
drawing me to it but either way I'll
take it you know it's a it's a magical
world filled of with mystery and
possibility that's what we do in film
and television and this is such a
heightened level of that it's so
exciting to come and play in the
playground every day with the people and
the creatively on in all aspects of the
film and television making from behind
the scenes to us being in front of the
cameras and you know it obviously people
are responsive to it and we have the
best fan bases in the genres that we
work in and to know that you know people
are responding and coming and waiting
you know all night sleeping outside to
come see the product that we're making
just makes it so fulfilling and you know
we get to make you know silly stuff look
awesome
Andy would mark so what other characters
or what other corners of the DC Universe
have you guys thought about visiting for
the show what are we allowed to visit
Jeff I think one of the the great things
about the show is we get a chance to
visit
all these different quarters of the DC
Universe not just in 2016 but all
throughout all time so we'll be going to
some really not just incredible places
but incredible moments and I really
don't think I'm allowed to say anything
more than that
okay what about if you could go to any
time period wherever you take these
characters and why okay we'll move on
mark so Katie just going back to the
canary one of my favorite characters on
on arrow and I also thought I also
thought brilliantly re-envisioned a back
story for Black Canary I thought was
terrific what do you think is makes her
the most dangerous member of this team
why is she the most dangerous member of
this team I know the answer to this one
because she's not afraid to die I mean
she is died multiple times and I mean
imagine that like really imagine that
you have no fear of death every
situation that you go into I mean
there's this reckless abandonment that
you can have and really nothing can stop
her and you can't threaten her with
anything if you're not afraid of dying
like so that's why I think she's gonna
be pretty dangerous in this series in a
good way and speaking of dangerous again
going back to the Rogues Wentworth and
Dominic if you have a couple
time-traveling rogues what do you think
the first thing captain cold and heat
wave would do with the time machine
I think the 70s is that Starsky and
Hutch thing going on in the seventies
for you yeah not the 20s for me I'm a
romantic yeah I know it's impossible to
believe I actually am I'm a softy under
all these tattoos and nastiness
Wentworth what era but he's sticking
with the 70s Oh 17 just hanging out the
70s and I'm good
yeah yeah listen to disco okay yeah the
blonde boy really was okay wasn't that
great yeah but you Victor we're we're
we're munch tango what would you want to
do this is a man of science right so
time travel would be something crazy to
him yeah I don't know I'd go back to the
1800s I know Titanic oh that worked out
well I'm gonna go to Phil Phil climber
who's joining again a new new face to
the DC Universe great resume here Phil
why did you cuz I know just from talking
with everybody Warner Brothers and
develop and everything else that you
really have you know your pick of shows
to go to and work on and why did you
work and pick legends of tomorrow that
was one of the easier decisions I've
ever made there yes yes you but you know
I think you know being able to return to
the Berlanti family and you know I had a
great time with Tomorrow People
political animals Golden Boy and I've
spent my entire career at Warner
Brothers and to be able to do something
like this with a cast like this was
literally like a millisecond sort of
decision so yeah very excited well guys
this is we gotta wrap it up now but
thank you so much for again staying
tonight and legends of tomorrow watch
our own flash see these characters and
then get ready for a crazy kick guys
show thank you
you